it is and as the lawyers themselves
state to date so far they've decided to
stay quiet on this matter but it seems
very clear now that they have been fed
up with the fact that there seemed to
have been briefings coming from across
the Atlantic from America when it comes
to the dealings that been going on when
it comes to the prosecutors and also
Prince Andrew's legal team within this
statement they talk about misleading
media briefings inaccurate statements
and breaches of confidentiality by the
Department of Justice that have given an
entirely misleading account of our
discussions with them now within that
statement they also go on to say that
Prince Andrew on three separate
occasions has offered his assistance it
says the duke of york has on at least
three occasions this year offered his
assistance as a witness to the
department of justice unfortunately the
Department of Justice has reacted to the
first two offers by breaching their own
confidentiality rules and claiming that
the Duke has offered zero cooperation in
doing so they go and say that they are
perhaps seeking publicity rather than
accepting the assistants profit now this
statement comes after newspaper reports
this morning that actually federal
prosecutors over in New York have now
formally requested through the British
government that Prince Andrew as part of
their criminal investigation into
Jeffrey Epstein is brought forward
really to answer their questions
of course over the last ten years or so
there's been a huge amount of legal
doing and throwing and we've had huge
amounts of reports about letters being
sent from America here to the UK
requesting that Prince Andrew speaks
about his friendship which every Epstein
you may remember of course the interview
that Prince Andrew gave at the end of
last year where for the first time he
talked in details about his relationship
with Jeffrey Epstein Jeffrey Epstein of
course a billionaire but also a
convicted sex offender and it's worth
saying that Prince Andrew all along has
said that there was no wrongdoing when
it came to his relationship with Jeffrey
Epstein yes he stayed with him he stayed
in his home
New York but at no point did he see
anything that he believed should be
reported to the authorities but
certainly when he gave that interview
last year Prince Andrew said that he
would be willing to speak to any
American law enforcement agencies that
felt necessary to speak to him
however the American prosecutors
certainly at the start of this year was
saying look we've had zero cooperation
from Prince Andrew and his legal team
but this statement today is very
surprising but I think it has now
clearly become the time for his legal
team to speak out because they believe
that their client Prince Andrew is being
misrepresentative bitten being
misrepresented sorry and as they say he
has on three separate occasions agreed
to speak to them as they've requested
yeah and just to clear to be more clear
about is this formal request that has
come from the Department of Justice does
it what does what does that mean legally
for Prince Andrew doesn't you have to
cooperate so this is described as a
mutual legal assistance treaty and in
essence it's an agreement between two
states when it comes to them one states
investigating a criminal case and when
you have a person who lives in a
separate country in this case you've got
America saying to the UK look we want to
speak to Prince Andrew this is all going
through the Home Office but within this
statement the legal team are also
suggesting that again there has been
this breach in simply talking about the
fact that this has even existed also the
fact that today we've also had the home
office saying that is that it is their
long-standing policy if they're not to
confirm or deny what these mutual legal
assistance requests exists also over in
America you have the Southern District
of New York prosecutors and also the
Department of Justice also again
refusing to confirm whether or not this
has happened but certainly it does seem
to be there is now this more formal
process at this formal request in to
make sure that Prince Andrew now is made
in some ways
speaks the authorities but then again in
this statement it's very clear his legal
team are saying look we have already
said that Prince Andrew will speak as a
witness when it comes to the prosecutors
over in America still trying to dig down
into those crimes that were carried out
by Jeffrey Epstein